Ми зараз у майстерні моїй,
де робляться кобзарські інструменти.
Тут не завжди робиться, майструється,
а часто це робиться десь на колінах,
десь в полі, в лісі, в сусідів, в гостях, де прийдеться,
тому тут такого немає:
якихось верстатів величезних чи чогось такого,
того що все тут здебільшого робиться ручним способом,
без застосування  електроінструментів.
Тут не тільки інструменти новітні,
тут також у мене зберігаються
для зразків трохи і старовинні інструменти.
От, наприклад, оце скрипка старовинна, це з Миргородщини. Вдалось її купити.
Вона стара дуже, розклеєна, саморобна.
Робив якийсь народний майстер.
Тому що здавна всі майстри,
які робили кобзи, бандури,
зазвичай вміли робити і скрипки,
і віолончелі народні — басолі.
І тому вони в такому стилі.
Оце, наприклад, бандура 37-го року.
Також ось, наприклад, є теж старовинна бандура.
Це десь 20-х або 30-х років ХХ століття.
Ну, це давній інструмент, вдалося купити
колись на харківському базарі.
Харків і Миргород — це були
такі в Україні як столиці кобзарства.
У давні часи, як ви знаєте, багато було війн тоді,
нападів різних на наші землі
і було важко взагалі якось вижити будь-де.
Тому виживали, як на Запоріжжі, там в плавнях,
робили також у глухіших, лісистих селах.
Коли були всякі там перетурбації в XVII столітті, багато хто
з козацтва переселявся із Черкащини на Харківщину.
Тому багато навіть сіл з такими ж назвами на Харківщині
і, відповідно, переносили свій козацький побут.
Тут-то були невеликі хутори козацькі,
такі, що в недоступних місцях:
в балках якихось або навпаки на горбах,
як біля Полтави, в лісах якихось.
Але якраз із Черкащини з Правобережжя переселялось
дуже багато саме козацького чину людей, бойового.
Вони відбивалися, тут засновували хутори,
містечка, села і, відповідно, козацький побут,
і з ними ж і кобзарські інструменти: кобзи, бандури.
І це зберігається в літописах як саме
на Харківщині це було поширено.
І так вийшло, що біля Миргорода і на Харківщині,
що кобзарів було найбільше.
Тому воно ось так і зберігалось,
і дійшло до початку ХХ століття.
[грає колісна ліра]
Взагалі, кобзарська діяльність — це не тільки майстрова,
кожен майстер, він повинен вміти грати
на всіх інструментах, які він робить.
Але, крім того, що я майструю,
я починав з того, що я саме грати хотів.
Про майстрування я не дуже спочатку замислювався.
Я збирався грати, шукав собі інструмента.
Побачивши колись картинку «Козак Мамай»,
я хотів знайти таку кобзу десь,
а потім уже я замовив майстрові,
щоб ліру мені зробив одну.
Це ще 2005-го.
І тоді вже почав робити і майструвати сам.
2009 року я доробив свою першу бандуру.
Вона зараз в одного з моїх учнів, у Києві.
Потім і ліру зробив.
І вирішив навчитись, все ж таки, на кобзу,
на яких грає козак Мамай.
Тобто кобза — це такий інструмент,
на ньому грали не тільки сліпці:
кобзарі — професійні виконавці,
а також і козаки, чумаки. Саме от на кобзах таких.
[награє мелодію на кобзі]
Слід іще сказати, що в радянський час
не тільки кобзарів ловили, розстрілювали.
Була ще і з іншого боку дуже погана річ:
намагалися змінити кобзарські інструменти,
тобто бували аматори, яким,
наприклад, важко було навчитись грати,
вони думали, що треба змінити інструмент.
Вони не могли зробити хороші кілочки,
думали, що залізні будуть кращі.
Почали ставити залізні тоді, ніби вони міцніші будуть.
Але вони теж ламалися.
Тоді вони не вміли розколоти дерево,
щоб воно не тріснуло, і почали робити зі шматків.
Це все десь в 20-30х роках ХХ століття.
Радянська влада це заохочувала.
Почали робити навіть з бандуристів аматорів зрячих.
Такі от музичні колгоспи, як капели,
щоб грати гуртом щось,
і заохочували до того,
що в 1950-х роках вже зробили такий інструмент, як...
Зветься це хроматична бандура або концертна бандура.
Іноді її звуть так, між людей, басегла.
Від того, що вона дуже велика.
Вона важча десь в сім разів від нормальної бандури.
У ній оцих залізних кілків дуже багато,
струн там близько 60-ти,
і в державних капелах і досі ще використовують
ці радянські інструменти.
І воно ще досі триває,
але в них теж інструменти старі, радянські.
Тобто це зовсім інше явище, але, на жаль,
в радянський час це називали кобзарством,
і досі дехто вважає, називає кобзарством
оці радянські фабричні інструменти.
На Харківщині 100 років тому вчився хлопець такий —
Георгій Ткаченко.
Вчився він на художника
в художньому училищі харківському, в центрі.
Він якось гулявши по центру, по вулиці Пушкінській,
почув кобзаря харківського Петра Древченка,
він захопився, купив на базарі
(там, де я купив оцю стару бандуру),
він там купив теж бандуру собі
і почав потроху вчитись грати.
Бо його так захопило. Потім вчився в Москві,
коли був голод і війна. Він грав це для себе.
Приїхавши, побачив, що кобзарство фактично знищене,
бо там багатьох розстрілювали, арештовували.
Він тоді познайомився,
почав знаходити рештки кобзарства в Україні
і почав потроху вчити учнів собі.
Один з його учнів — це мій вчитель, Кость Черемський.
Тобто традиція все ж таки жива,
бо вона була передана від живих людей.
Тобто це не тільки з записів,
хоч вони теж важливі надзвичайно.
Ну то ми пробуємо грати те,
що і було вживу навчено, і те, що було по записах.
В кінці 1980-х років коло учнів Георгія Ткаченка, а також тих,
хто цим цікавились, вирішили відродити на взір давніх цехів.
Бо кобзарі зазвичай об'єднувались в кобзарські цехи.
Ну і вирішили, на зразок таких цехів,
зробити цех загальний.
Це десь уже після 2005-го року.
Тобто це не значить, що всі ходять, як я,
мандрують десь і грають на бандурі на базарі.
А просто ті, що почали грати або тільки вчаться,
або тільки майструють, здебільшого.
Або навчились грати і потрошки грають,
тобто це завжди об'єднувались не тільки майстри якісь,
а також учні всі, або ті, що кобзарський
репертуар знають, але без інструменту.
Я, взагалі, викладаю в університеті архітектурному
на кафедрі «Урбаністики» я викладаю містобудування.
Ну я вчився ж на архітектора, і багато зараз хто,
як і Георгій Ткаченко, був за фахом архітектор,
той, що навчився. Ще навіть незрячий.
Так і зараз, багато хто в Києві,
вони теж архітектурної освіти, тому що
майструвати — треба щоб був або художник, або архітектор.
Кобзарство — це не тільки музичне виконавство,
а також це спілкування з людьми,
також це і конструювання інструментів,
а також розроблення логістики досягнення якихось цілей,
і так далі, і таке інше, маршрутів розроблення і все таке.
Тобто воно дуже багато схожих моментів,
воно допомагає знаннями одне іншому.
Ну здебільшого дехто спочатку не розуміє що це,
але більшість, в принципі, сприймає це звичайно.
Тому що це не є якоюсь пропагандою партійною,
це і не є жебрацтвом,
а це окрема, як фах, така професія.
Тому що я, наприклад, пропоную комусь слухати гру,
а він за це може мені, якщо вважає за потрібне,
дати якісь гроші чи хліб, чи щось таке.
Тобто відбувається такий обмін.
Я — одне, а вони інше.
І тому оце іде завжди без нав'язування.
І коли я граю, я спеціально без всяких підсилювачів,
тобто кому треба — він може підійти і послухати.
Ну і в Харкові цікава річ тим, слава Богу, що люди
все ж таки впізнають інструмент і розуміють все це.
А у Києві і у Львові багато хто не розуміє кобзарства,
вони не сприймають, що це така професія — грати надворі.
Не розуміють що це за інструмент такий і так далі.
Тобто таке сприйняття якесь туристичне.
А в Харкові і в Миргороді люди сприймають
що це і немає питань: «Що це ви робите?»
Тобто зазвичай все це воно,
слава Богу, що так,
і треба це підтримувати, намагатись.
Ну і в давні часи кобзарів не було десятки і сотні тисяч.
Завжди було їх небагато.
Тому намагаємось якось тримати хоч потроху.